brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the front
lines at South by Southwest and we're
going to talk about Kingdom it's a game
in which you build yourself a kingdom
but it's a little bit different and it's
got a very distinctive style I think
you're gonna like it with me is Kathy
and Kathy a kingdom doesn't build itself
and in Kingdom it's your job to pretty
much raised it up from nothing exactly
so it's a side-scrolling game where
you're collecting assets you start with
nothing you get a few assets you start
with a campfire and then you have to
recruit people to join your kingdom you
have to give them jobs and then they
start to create resources for you and
it's all about management and it's
interesting the side-scrolling aspect of
it is one of the most distinctive things
I think because i think management i
think top-down view I think I got the
bird's-eye view i'm sort of putting
resources here and there but here you're
literally running back and forth which I
think kind of channels that like it is
actually probably pretty hard to run a
kingdom well there's definitely places
where you can get a little excited I've
seen people playing this weekend where
they just seem to be jumping up and down
in their chair and they're getting
really anxious that they don't have
enough coins but then other people are
really going with the Zen of it and just
kind of going back and forth doing what
they can do the nice thing about it is
when you die you just start over so it's
not just about get as much as you can as
fast as you can you've got that
management element but you've also got
the chance to regrow so game over
doesn't always mean game over yeah
there's a kind of emphasis on the
continuity of the realm right and it did
and it's not just about you know it's
not about that one King one lifetime of
one monarch it's sort of a cross which
is kind of a nice way to sort of soften
that otherwise sometimes brutal like
rogue like you you're done all your
progress is gone because you sort of
feel some momentum and carry through
between playthroughs exactly and you can
say but what I've seen is people just
want to see how far they can go
you know and you can expand your kingdom
you can get farms you'll eventually find
shrines you can get nights when you get
far enough into it and there are
monsters yeah there's some urgency here
because it's not all peaceful in the
kingdom of kingdom exactly and so as
you're collecting you want to thank keep
in mind that you've got defenses you
need you have to defend your people and
if you're not defending them then when
the monsters come they're going to take
your assets and I think the interesting
thing about the monsters is they go for
the shiny things they're not there
they're not trying to like hack their
way through your Battlement and then
hack their way through your second
Battlement they just rush it and they're
going for you because you have the crown
on your head and that that crown leaves
your head if they get it first no crown
no Kingdom no crown no Kingdom ah but
Kingdom playable here on the show floor
at South by Southwest and tell us when
it's coming out and to what platforms
it's actually out now it's on steam for
pc awesome and they do extra content
every couple of months the next release
of new content is March twenty second
which is always free to people that
already own the game so yeah look
forward to that very cool Kingdom on
steam new stuff coming just next week
give it a look